here we go 27 ticks before kickoff
please start smoothly this time start
smoothly this time quick run down war
zone rated there are 55 players entered
so far more can enter while the
tournament's going on at this point 55
average rating 1790 time handicapped as
usual 30-minute tournament anybody can
enter no level experience required here
we go let's go what are we gonna have Oh
Jackson 88 here we go efore I'm glad
that it's starting I'm glad that I
actually get to play the first round ah
oh they're doing all they gave me a they
gave me a chance yes back to tournament
who's in first oh that was an odd
purpose that was an on purpose Jackson
knows better he's doing that on purpose
alright I'm gonna play a six oh it's too
late for a six I want to get any five
okay this looks awkward because I'm
blocking my EEP on but I'm gonna do it
anyhow
'if I've coming up oh man okay I have
rapid development my opponents piling up
on this night but I have enough defense
for it those pawns don't capture like
that let's go get out of the pin push
push my opponent round Oh H pawn No
let's do this I want to shut the door on
the bishop shut the door not so fast
let's go here they were probably
expecting that let's do this tuck my
bishop back
actually let's throw him in a pin pond
push where does my knight want to be
let's do this first get rid of that
light square or the dark square Bishop
let's do this I'm not sure why Oh why'd
I open up that diagonal okay wait this
is all right let's do this
I want to get rid of the dark square
bishop soon dr. bishop you got to leave
he's not leaving oh okay I have to keep
the G file closed
okay that's I'm breathing a sigh relief
okay 25 ticks left each come
no keep it closed right here Queen takes
pawn lateral movement smashed through on
g6 oh that one's pretty slick that was a
slick move right there but I got a tempo
tempo gainer shut the door in the dark
square Bishop my knight has a good spot
let's go Knight hit the rook how much
time
give me that night take that night and
then I don't know what that even know
what that is even doing what is that
doing okay can I get that pond how much
time do they have that's me is it close
to me this is me double check mate I
know it's made on b3 the broadcaster
blocked by determined okay six six six
five and a bunch of two's here we go
Hampton two two two two let's go let's
go feels good to be able to play without
the glitches in the beginning that was
good that was good and also to get um a
quick mate and on purpose and on purpose
that one was ah but it's not good to see
this Hampton clock ticking doubled the
stakes so this is a good sign
if they're not going to move I get yes
quick resign 12 I'm up there
12 12 here we go Slav is he gonna play
the Slav no maybe I'll play the Slav no
no not gonna do that okay
tempo gainers 96 now I probably should
have taken that but okay when I get this
pond push and Bishop d6 I'm launching it
it's engaged it's engaged right here now
let's support this I'm going to capture
like this I'm fearful like the bishop
check and stuff okay here we go
Knight g5 be very prepared for it no I
need that guy he's in a key ingredient
he's a key ingredient but I guess we're
gonna go without Queen's now I should
have taken the Queen's before I
recaptured Ani
alright well and game land my king wants
to play where does he want to be if he's
gonna play where is it where does he
want to be right here hit the night my
king is gonna be playing soon
it's guard this and my bishops freedom
move let's chop this oh this is winning
material material winner that's not
there was block on f1 oh I'm on the roof
this is reliant resigned time resigned
time defend the night this has got to be
made really soon back to term in twenty
twenty twelve twelve 625 and change come
on let's go you got to keep winning this
is a strong player okay we're gonna have
mainline care off or not Oh what's there
light square bishop doing what's right
light square bishop doing okay now
let's support this and get here and here
Oh h4 h5 h4 h5 this will give me a
brutal brutal it's dead it's a debt he's
a dead man
the pawns dead and the H files opened up
I insist
chop I don't know if I do it in the
right way but my Knights are finding
good squares my queen is going to come
out let's take this pawn let's give a
check get rid of that light square
bishop and then do what next I'm not
sure oh I have an idea I have an idea
I know Queen can't go here my Knights
defending also learn that was a false
alarm right there when I take that gasp
that's a false alarm gasp ok so the rook
is dead
cooked rook Queen is out just having fun
go over here discovered tricks Oh
discovered tricks get out of the tricks
pawn push counter punch I'm in a pin I
got a I got a plate ok I would have had
to play b3 but not now get rid of the
knight
come here hit the pawn I want a rook I'm
not going to take that pawn I probably
should but okay I'll see here's good too
I'm on the Queenie I'm on the bishop
checks Oh over here h-file this is the
way to open it up open it up over here
one pig is already on the seventh
I'm looking for another here we go this
is going to be a brutal one right check
come on over here Queen looking for
mates mates are right around the corner
that's check and then mate back to
tournament thirty eight thirty twenty
twenty oh man man 38 points we could get
paired up there's actually um you know
less than what 60 players in this
tournament so it could happen it could
definitely happen get d5 in before it's
too late okay are they going to take
then I have an advantage okay I have the
f5 Square no no let's come here pin the
knight Knight to this square is going to
be a killer it's a killer he's a dead
night cook night take with the bishop
and then pivot about on the f5 square
not not just yet
let's get this in now let's do this B 5
and then C 4 is the plan let's take this
pawn because I could be 5 c4 I still
want to get that in I want to take out
that bishop ok it's still out the game
or is it it is there passed pawn I'm on
f4 f4 Knight f5 coming up dropping that
pawn
that's alright though isn't it move oh
my mouse is terrible to me what did I do
to deserve that forks forks get behind
this and push is my pawn faster he's got
to go I can't deal with that
f7 Oh little scary a little scary or a
lot scary ok
Queen Queen Queen ok they resigned yes
okay that's alright I trying to say
Queen to e1 what it was what I was going
to do next okay what do we have
oh oh it's the leader of the pack it's
the pack leader this is a key game we're
gonna have oh oh here we go
game on give a check ah pins pins checks
would we have grabbed this I really want
to avoid that I should get the dark
square control tower Square control Oh
be very scared get that Bishop
give me the bishop give me the bishop
give me Bishop
I want that bishop why isn't you give me
the bishop oh this is scary time let's
do this
am I in a fork probably real close to it
this is getting scary this is getting
scary oh let's go over here
oh I'm dropping pieces or am I was that
a save it might have been no it's not
okay I got to go quick for karu skis the
Queen dead no she's not
oh I dropped a pond what am i doing what
are we doing here what are we doing
Queen trade not so fast
oh my Knights covering stuff would we
have Forks uh-oh
over here I don't know what that's doing
but I'm gonna do it
oh man it's very scary over here right
here is this working out somehow it's
not working out no it's not working out
how much time do I have
can I get this somehow Queen Trey and I
just want a clean trade I just dropped a
piece oh I want to cry in between her is
that working I don't have any time I'm a
dead man
why they do that what
I don't have any time I don't have any
time ah ah oh man that was a key one
right there
ah oh man where did my time go it went
with all the defensive moves ah
that was key could we get paired up
again
or maybe I could still win can I still
win even though I lost that one I'm not
I'm not giving up h 2 h 2 is where it's
at H 2
I'm back in the thick of things Oh guess
who's that going away
54 I'm not going away I'm not letting
that stop me from winning I'm not
letting it stop me I'm not I'm not going
down that easily age to be very scared
pink pieces pile up on the pimpies here
we go f7 f7 f7 f7 here
oh my bishops dead no it's not Forks f7
I kept saying f7 now it's there hit the
whole family the family's getting hit oh
man that was a tough one to stomach here
we go here we go pawn push f5 open it up
for this uh dark square bishop you can
do it you can do it don't you dare give
up don't you dare think of giving up
okay
Queen check Queen check there's gonna be
a bishop block and stuff though isn't
there okay I got a pin paint on the
night let's go over here I guess the
night is still pinned let's open it up
checks this could be a giant thorn Oh or
not or no oh now it is it's back to
being a thorn what is my okay my Queens
doing nothing Oh Queen h4 I should have
played let's do it now how much time
okay there's enough time let's go give
me these dark square Bishop snow
let's go with the Queen check the after
block go here kill the night kill the
night I should I should let me do this
that night is still kind of dead or is
it ah okay forks
we're in the forks let's get this uh
these pawns going oh I just dropped upon
let's try this
how much time get out of there Bishop
this is check I'm gonna get rid of the
tricky night get rid of that tricky
night first before you do anything else
get rid of the tricky night take the
pond and then come back here push this
guy things should be okay now check
check and then okay I got the bishop get
out of the way check and then mate how
much time that one took way too long
okay back to chairman 106 106 seventy ah
man
see five Hampton to two two to resign
yes that's what I like to see 106
eighty-eight we could still be paired up
myself in Kappa rot it could be paired
up still still a lot of time a lot of
game a lot of game left okay get that
night light squared bishop no let's do
this
you take that now no okay let me get
over here I want to go with this rook so
I have F 2 covered let's get rid of this
night and then post here let's chase the
Queen away a little bit
now that was stupid I shouldn't have
done that I'm in trouble oh oh actually
let me do this because I'm on the bishop
and the Queen and I want to get to e 6 e
6 actually this move next guard G 2 I'm
on the Queen may be Queen G 4
let's do this Queen G for that
should solve a lot of problems here a
lot of the pressure will go away as soon
as the Queen's are off and now I'm on e6
and I want to kick this night away get
out of their night and let's can test
this file right here I want to play rook
b3 that might do rip b6 okay they're
being stubborn very good it's the way to
do it okay let's do this and I still
have this covered they're going to
repair that they repaired it repaired
pawn structure pawn push and then rook
to h1 okay I have a passed pawn over
here by force
oh okay that's a let me do it no let's
go over here watch that pawn and just
push and rook to route to be two I
should have done work to be two to stop
the pivot on that square I think that
would have sealed it or would it of um I
don't know what I'm doing with that move
just anything time burners I need the
game's not gonna finish just anything
anything time burners checks checks
okay back to chairman 108 146 Wow
146 108 ah man that's tough now what I'm
gonna take that potty Oh what is that
Quincy seven um can I get g4 in Knight
g4 I mean no we're not we're not having
that let's go here maybe the bishop will
take that pawn it's probably good but I
don't know I get the B file or something
I got the B file
give me the light square bishop yes
light square weaknesses move the knight
I got the rook I got the Queen come on
this is time to resign I should have
given a check I should have given a
check there ah I would have been better
if I would have given a check instead of
taking the Queen right away
I was probably leading to mate somehow
there's no quick wins yeah I'm not
getting I'm not getting a quick win
right here
Oh what's happening just thrown the
house at me
kitchen sink variation one Pig on the
second looking for another one Pig
looking for another Oh discover Czech
territory discover check and then mate
assume can go here King go here it's
safer isn't it no it's not I was a lie I
was lying on that one okay where's the
mate what am i could be captured okay
let's go like this I can still be
captured okay mate one or two close to
it mate next no the night's gonna give a
check notes now okay back to tournament
126 166 128 twelve minutes and change
okay still it could happen could it
still happen oh is it my within striking
distance still come on come on come on
come on Bishop c4 target f7 okay I'm
gonna take with the ponderize Knight f6
there's a little fork right there c3 ah
so much for what okay well I got this
pun get my pieces out and then what okay
my bishop I want to play here if it's
attacked actually even if it's not
attacked okay let's come over here I'm
on aged seven Bishop g5 okay move knight
move knight um what do i do what do I do
rook right here oh that's just a hanging
piece take the knight I might I got me
got me yes
I almost mouse slipped I think I went to
age six instead age seven honest 176 148
14 games and 14 games let's go here see
five more tempos I'm going to get a temp
I got the night come on what's happening
here is it was this an on purpose was
this a mistake or an on purpose okay
let's go with this I guess I'm on the
Queen oh come on this is time to resign
isn't it yes back to term at 168th whoo
I'm in striking distance 176 168 don't
count me out
don't count me out 11 minutes 11 minutes
minutes fumbling with the words pond
takes gambit go for a gambit line bishop
right here and looking for f7 f7
actually let me try this it looks really
committal but I'm gonna do it okay let's
go h7 h7 work look up and over is the
plan look up and then over resign are
they gonna resign that's me Oh
87 again who's in first Oh 188 186 I
think you might be ready to win though
Hampton - 2 - here we go Hampton double
the points and resign that's the plan is
it yeah that's 208 and just like that
who's in first now who didn't give up
who didn't quit ah be very prepared for
anything
prepare for anything here we go now that
you have a lead you have to try to
extend it stay focused here stay focused
now focus
f5 break it open h6 look for mates hit
the knight backup to h3 let's try it
again I'm not gonna repeat rinse and
repeat all right I'm gonna do it even if
it's wrong I'm doing it Knight g5 take
on E
and then kill the knight get made on
each seven you know what I'm talking
about
okay I get this pawn at least kick the
King around a little bit check check
check Knight d5
let's go Knight do
something B contributor contribute no I
don't want to Queen trade maybe I should
have done a clean trade okay get out of
there Queen we're gonna have a queen
trade that's all right lock down on
these ponds okay it's not gonna be a
quick win but hopefully it's just still
win no I don't want you guys to play
over here watch over the dark squares
forks forks everywhere for County six I
got the rookie got the rook he's a dead
man the rook is dead
pins oh they didn't take my knight that
was a mouse slipper I did a mouse
slipper right there 20 17 seconds let's
go trade I'm up the exchange move quick
quicker than you um quick just just
quick just move quick I'm trying to say
ah run pond run pond you want to play
give a check don't let your time tick
kill the night
push the pond not so fast let's go go go
go no stalemates that's looking like it
might be stalemate ha ha let's not let's
just do this I was looking like it might
be stalemate don't be stale may and
might have been closest day only to 28
ah somebody slipped up somebody slipped
up I know how it feels
ah 228 yes quick resigner
i'm getting showered with points right
now I'm reigning points for Team
chestnut work ah what do we got
Oh points for everybody I might have
points to spare Oh gonna happen points
to spare just kick that night out there
take the night I have control of f6 so
you know what that means fishing poles
get your fishing poles ready fishing
pole there's the pole I'm ready to hook
the hook the bait here come on give a
check I block you back up back up
Oh why'd I do that I thought it was
covered watch I'm not going to take the
bishop castle she
took that okay that was bad I'm being
too sneaky here I gotta win these Oh
what's happening just castle no I want
my tricky night on the board
tricky night tricky nights tricky night
I want to get to d6 I should have just
taken that back I'm getting too fancy
don't get fancy win not for the fancy
stuff 96 it's very scary it's very scary
Oh f 7 f 7 is in the air hit the Queen
chase her away from the bishop hit the
bishop again I'm on the Queen I'm on the
Queen the queen is dead dead Queen ah no
no no no no no no what did I just do
Oh No what's going on here oh the rook
is gonna give a check no it's not the
Knights gonna give a check no it's not
the bishops gonna kill me all I want to
cry
the Knights gonna give a check Oh pieces
are falling everywhere I'm a dead man
how much time is left I want to cry run
King please just run run run run look at
the position I'm in you need cubby I
need to have I'm in trouble I'm a dead
man there's no way out is there there's
no way out could I win this no I can't
I made it soon I'm getting mated Oh am I
gonna win this no way I got a block how
much time they're just gonna burn my
time right is it mate
I got my kings running away he's running
away he's really fast
is he really fast how much time don't
make me don't make me don't make me
don't make me tell me meat I want I want
my oh that was so Ted's right there Wow
I had that one in the bag didn't I you
know just a couple pawns versus like an
entire army is winning
Oh forfeit it on time oh man I'm going
dizzy right now I feel really dizzy
after that one how much time is left you
got to keep going there's no time to
breathe in these tournaments no time for
breathing you just got to go quick
let's go g5 open it up oh man talk about
blunder city after blunder City on that
one oh man get out of there Bishop you
have no business Oh requesting no no no
no give me that give me give me give me
give me me oh okay
chop here and then chop the night come
on resign time the queen is close to
dead or is she where is my queen dead
last time I fired my opponent's Queen
was dead and then my clean was dead two
seconds later chop that up my knight is
dead okay let's do this
regroup here I'm up a rope focus now
queenside castle everything is nice and
cozy looking for the cozy positions no
no no no no hang on sneaky stuff just
give me that rook take them no I don't
want this Queen do I go over there so
I'm no fun okay King let's go get over
here
how much time three minutes and change
double up get this pawn next and
everything is going to be quite alright
isn't it get the rope get rid of that
pawn actually let me get this pawn one
pig on the third the pigs could be fun
be found on the third rank - this is the
new this is the new second rank the
third rank the pigs are hungry hungry
pigs hungry pigs check looking for me
either one the rook has to go to defend
check no no let's just take this and
then just push my pawn to victory push
push push push
nothing to be done he's really fast fast
pawn mate back determined 278 244
gonna get that 278 244 let's go let's go
you got to win one more if I think if I
win one more Oh what do we got what do
we got
efore okay there's time to get this game
in so just focus don't drop your queen
note to self don't that little Queen I
thought that Queen you know don't drop
that Queen okay we are playing the the
copycat game right now who's copying who
is black copying me okay d4 push them
around capture at the a get the a file
I'm gonna go like this no I'm gonna win
upon one pun okay how's the clock
situation oh let me get that Bishop out
of there
gotta go you gotta go bishop actually
Bishop f4 or not not so fast
no way okay Knight here I go on a pit I
throw it in a pin and now there's tanks
and also a pin pressure on the knight
take out h6 kill the knight okay force
the pawn move and now I'm on the knight
Queen takes pawn I guess defends oh well
I got this though how much time okay
we're about even with time oh let's just
trade Queens ladies you're off ladies
need to leave and now hang on oh the
seventh rank let's defend that now
dangerous that could be
let's go King you want to play ah the
Knights dead though he's a dead man dead
man he knows he's dead if he goes there
and that's why I didn't go there okay
let's try this again
get out of there Knight no oh I didn't
mean to do that I didn't mean to do that
watch out for the mates careful careful
careful okay everything's under control
one minute left one minute warning
kill the knight okay time to resign
resign time they're not resigning come
on go go go check they got a block
looking for mates what am i doing come
on this is bad right here okay pre-move
pre-move time
just anything am I getting I better not
be getting mated just push what's
happening here over here there's no time
ticking off my opponents clock right
here there we go nice and cozy give a
check more checks more checks back to
German 298 254 oh that's it there's no
fear no fear I can't be cat there's no
being taught top of the points they beat
me to doubling the points they can
resign get over 300 318 oh man
318 that's it unless there's a quick
mate another resigner another resigner I
got ten now first place first place I
didn't get the points for that last
resigner right there everybody was
throwing points at me
ah good games ah winner oh man that was
crazy
ah 328 is a lot of points but it was not
without a lot of resigner huh ah the war
zone Kings that is exhausting